in 1977 the american civil liberties
union went to court to defend the rights
of american nazis
[Music]
the village of skokie illinois home to
many holocaust survivors
tried to prevent the national socialist
party of america
from holding a demonstration in its
streets ira glasser was then the head of
the new york civil liberties union
they should have ignored these people
when conor skokie responded and said you
better not come here we won't let
you they had an opportunity for
publicity of the kind that they could
never get
the aclu defended the nazis right to
march winning the case on first
amendment grounds
but at a high cost thirty thousand
members left the organization in protest
but skokie more than any other case
cemented the aclu's reputation as an
unwavering and principled defender of
the first amendment
willing to stand up for the rights of
even the most odious members of society
to freely speak their minds
we weren't representing the nazis we
were trying to oppose the government
glasser understood that if the
government were permitted to silence a
nazi
it could use that same power against
anyone deemed a radical
or a threat to the status quo i used to
say to black students in the 90s who
wanted to have hate speech codes on
college campuses that barred
hateful speech that had been in effect
on college campuses in the 60s malcolm x
would have been their most frequent
victim
and maybe eldridge cleaver but not david
duke the year after skokie glasser would
become the organization's executive
director
a position he would hold for the next 23
years
now he's the subject of a new
documentary mighty ira
that celebrates his time at the aclu in
real terms
it highlighted the issue of why would
you
ever want to defend the rights of people
like that it basically
forced me to articulate
reasons for the first amendment
positions that the aclu took
in the most hostile and uncomfortable
circumstances but glasser who retired in
2001
now fears that the organization that
grew into a nationwide civil liberties
powerhouse on his watch
has backed away from the principled
stance exemplified by skokie
in 2017 the aclu was criticized for
defending the organizers of the unite
the right rally in charlottesville
virginia
a few months after that students
associated with black lives matter at
william and mary
shouted down an aclu speaker
the following year a leaked memo offered
guidelines for future case selection
in which the aclu seemed to retreat from
its long-standing content neutral stance
citing as a factor to consider when
deciding to take a case
the extent to which the speech may
assist in advancing the goals of white
supremacists
or others whose views are contrary to
our values that memo did in fact
unarguably introduce a content-based
consideration to whether or not they
would take a free speech case
enough so it made me wonder if skokie
case happened again with the aclu take
it and i
i don't know glasser says there's never
a conflict between pursuing social
justice
and defending free speech quite the
opposite my major passion was social
justice too
particularly racial justice but my
experience was
free speech wasn't an antagonist it was
an ally
it was a critical ally there is no
social justice movement
in america that has ever not needed the
first amendment
to initiate its movement for justice to
sustain
its movement to justice to help its
movement survive john lewis who said
that
without free speech and the right to
dissent the civil rights movement
would have been a bird without wings and
that's
historically and politically true
without exception
so for people who today claim
to be passionate about social justice
for them to establish free speech
as an enemy is suicidal i mean where
would the black lives matter movement be
without the right to free speech the
only important question about a speech
restriction
is not who is being restricted but who
gets to decide
who is being restricted if it's going to
be decided by joe mccarthy if it's going
to be decided by richard nixon if it's
going to be decided by rudy giuliani if
it's going to be decided by trump or
william barr then most of the social
justice advocates are going to be on the
short end of that decision
it's not politically outrageous during
times like this for the aclu
to want to become more of a political
organization
and the civil liberties organization the
problem with it
for civil liberties is that there's a
lot of progressive
political groups out there and i'm glad
to have more of them because that's my
politics too but there's only one aclu
and if the aclu takes itself off the
stage of defending
speech on a content neutral basis
because it's too
too dangerous to allow the government
the power to decide
so it doesn't matter in whose behalf the
immediate
client is what matters is you have to
stop the government from gaining the
power to decide
if the aclu steps off that stage even
slightly
who's going to replace it